shamatya today he's talking to uh uh Lex
I think he's talking to Lex he's on his
podcast and the conversation was about
uh America with the interest rates and
what we're doing and Powell and
increasing the rates we can't afford a
war right now because you know money is
so expensive for us right now that we
couldn't finance a war right now you
know where us we're not ready for some
like that how much of that is true like
do you think if something did happen in
America needed a finance a war it
wouldn't be you know they would still do
it versus how much you think rates and a
person like Powell you know he called
them the most powerful man in the world
because him increasing the rate is
preventing America from being on Attack
Mode where you have to kind of take the
step back do you agree with them warship
never ever be about whether we can or
cannot afford it War should only be
about do we have no choice but to fight
it
and if you have no choice but to fight
it then you're gonna fund it